negotiations between the white house and
republican lawmakers about president
biden's proposed infrastructure plan
continue
however both sides remain far apart on
the cost of the overall plan and how to
pay for it
it's leading some democrats to map out a
different plan one that would not need
republican backing
christina raffini has the latest from
the white house christina good morning
good morning jeff well the phrase let's
make a deal might get people excited on
a certain popular game show
but not everyone in washington is so
thrilled at the prospect of president
biden
having having a deal made with
republicans to get them to sign on to
his infrastructure plan
a small group gathered outside the white
house friday to protest
compromise biden which side are you on
some progressives argue that the
president shouldn't give in to
republican demands on his infrastructure
bill
now's the time to accelerate the process
we've been making
the original plan called for building
not just roads and bridges
but a stronger social safety net at a
cost of 2.3 trillion dollars
we have a chance to seize on the
economic momentum
of the first months of my administration
not just to build back but to build back
better republicans balked at the price
tag
and a plan to pay for it by raising the
corporate tax rate
and increasing taxes on high-income
earners president biden has since
offered to lower his ass to one trillion
dollars
but the parties still can't agree on how
to pay for it
one of the suggestions that we made to
the administration
is to repurpose some of this
extraordinary amount of money that's
gone out
to state and local governments across
the country
republicans want to redirect unused
coveted relief funds for some of the
infrastructure projects
the white house does not he's obviously
come down
quite a bit in what he originally
proposed
and hopefully they'll have more they can
add to their proposal
president biden spoke by phone friday
with senator shelly moore capito
who's leading negotiations for the
republicans the two plan to speak again
on monday
but if all that talk doesn't turn into
action senate democrats have signaled
they're willing to go it alone
the president is also offering a new way
to play for that plan that's a 15
percent minimum corporate tax
and jeff that's because 55 percent of
major corporations didn't pay
any federal income tax last year which
most of us could say the same
okay christina thank you very much